[Musique]
exactement théoriquement le gouvernement
est minoritaire mais il a une entente
avec le NPD qui est très pas tombé d'ici
2025 si on en faisait un certain nombre
de choses dont un plan de soins dentaire
pour les enfants alors on peut
s'attendre à ce que ça soit dans le
budget et aussi s'attendent donc à ce
que nous ne partirons pas en campagne
électoral à la fin de la journée là mais
effectivement il va y avoir un certain
nombre d'augmentation de dépenses mais
très ciblées parce que l'autre but du
budget aussi c'est de reprendre le
contrôle sur les dépenses pendant toute
la pandémie pendant tout ce temps là la
plupart des gens étaient d'accord avec
le gouverneur de la Banque du Canada
pour éteindre le feu mais là il faut
reprendre un peu le contrôle sur les
dépenses et c'est pour ça qu'on verra
pas beaucoup de nouvelles dépenses sauf
cette situation là sur les soins
dentaires parce que vraiment au coeur de
l'Entente qualité Clément Gignac je le
disais il y a dépression pour qu'elle
dépense davantage madame truelin en même
temps donnez-moi un portrait pour les
gens de de l'ampleur de la dette
canadienne et du déficit il faut bien
penser que la pandémie on était quand
même sur un ratio d'entêtement là autour
de 30 31% du PIB Patrice et avec cette
pandémie et les centaines de milliards
qu'on a dû investir pour éviter une
dépression comme vous savez le ratio
bondit à 43 45% du PIB donc on est dans
la bonne nouvelle s'il y en a une
là-dedans c'est tourner encore le pays
le moins entêté du G7 parce que toutes
les pays ont été frappés par la pandémie
donc ce qui va être intéressant et
c'était dans mes attentes que je vais
mentionner ce réseau sociaux et vos
collègues est-ce qu'il y aura un ancrage
budgétaire est-ce qu'on va présenter un
budget qui déprime parce que l'automne
dernier quand on regardait les
projections de Madame Freeman à sa
process de l'équipe budgétaire donc on
va avoir la réponse de Gérald dans
quelques minutes là-dessus oui je vous
rappelle mesdames et messieurs
que Gérald Filion et Madeleine lesmorin
dès qu'ils peuvent se brancher dès que
la ministre se lève le huis clos
budgétaire élevé donc on pourra vous
donner tous les détails de ce budget là
pour l'instant on ne peut pas
l'imaginaire qui a eu la gentillesse de
venir avec nous des
15h55 vous avez vous avez assisté à un
huis clos mais vous ne pouvez pas en
parler puis on respecte tout à fait ça
c'est le secret donc budgétaire Michel C
il y a déjà eu des cas des années où ce
secret a été inventé puis il y a eu des
conséquences là
on a vu un budget déposé
à la salle des conférences de presse par
le ministre des Finances parce que il y
avait eu tellement de questions de
privilèges
le temps avait passé toutes sortes de
choses comme ça à cause de ce code
madame flene qui s'est levé on va
écouter quelques minutes de la ministre
des Finances on pourra avec Gérald que
vous avez aperçu et Madeleine tout vous
dire on écoute quelques minutes
j'aimerais déposer dans les deux langues
officielles les documents budgétaires de
2023 y compris les avis de mention de
voix et moyenne
les détails des mesures figurent dans
ces documents
conformément l'article directement 83-2
je demande à ce que ces notions soient
inscrites à l'ordre du jour
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
l'économie du Canada c'est
rétabli depuis la récession de la covid
l'an dernier le Canada peut se targuer
d'avoir eu la plus forte croissance
économique du G7
il y a 830 000 plus de Canadiens qui
travaillent aujourd'hui que quand nous
avons été frappés par la covid
[Applaudissements]
nous avons recouvré 126% des emplois qui
avaient été perdus pendant les premiers
mois
contre juste 114% aux États-Unis
quand nous avons annoncé un système pan
canadien de garde d'enfants et
d'apprentissage précoce
dans notre budget de 2021
nous avons dit que cela créerait de
nouvelles occasions économiques pour les
mères partout au Canada
et que cela favoriserait ainsi une plus
grande prospérité pour nous tous et
savez-vous quoi Monsieur le Président ça
a marché
je suis fier de pouvoir dire que le mois
dernier la participation au marché du
travail des femmes canadiennes dans la
force de l'âge
a atteint un niveau record 85,7%
.
alors allons tout de suite si vous le
voulez bien mesdames et messieurs donner
les fessaillants avec Gérald et
madeleines Gérald bonsoir bonne fin
d'après-midi Madeleine merci alors
Gérald on vous écoute budget qui
présente apparemment un déficit plus
important de prévu ouais c'est important
que ce qui avait été annoncé dans la
mise à jour économique avant Noël
difficile budgétaire donc de 40
milliards de dollars pour l'exercice
2023 24 donc l'exercice pour lequel on
présente le budget aujourd'hui et ça
suit un déficit de 43 milliards donc qui
est plus important qu'attendu également
dans la mise à jour et on vient retirer
toutes les cibles de retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire on avait 27 28
dans la mise à jour là il n'y a pas de
retour à l'équilibre budgétaire les
dépenses augmentent les déficits
augmentent la détogne et le retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire ne fait plus
partie du plan prévisible sur cinq ans
du gouvernement fédéral la dette elle
est rendue à 1181 milliards de dollars
une dette qui passe de 42,4% de la
valeur de l'économie à 43,5 % ce sont
les comparables les plus crédibles quand
on quand on regarde par rapport au PIB
par rapport à l'économie on voit que la
dette augmente mais l'objectif est quand
même de faire baisser la dette à moyen
et à long terme pour la ramener sous la
barre des 40% du PIB en 2028 je vous
dirais que le point central de ce budget
Patrice qui a été présenté aujourd'hui
c'est l'économie propre les technologies
propres les
électricité l'énergie renouvelable 80
milliards de dollars sur 10 ans on
annonce la création d'un crédit d'impôt
de 15% pour fabriquer de l'électricité
propre du solaire de l'éolien des
batteries de l'énergie nucléaire et ce
crédit d'impôts de 15% sur l'électricité
propre Hydro-Québec qui aura accès comme
Ontario Power ou toutes les sociétés
d'État au Canada qui font de la
production électrique pourront avoir
accès à ce crédit d'impôt qui a pour
objectif d'électrifier davantage le
Canada
extraction équipements crédit d'impôts
de 30% d'une valeur de 11 milliards de
dollars extraction de minéraux
stratégiques pour la filière batterie
les crédits d'impôts prévus pour
l'hydrogène 18 milliards de dollars la
banque de l'infrastructure qui va
injecter 20 milliards dans l'énergie
propre les technologies propres et
d'autres mesures de 5 milliards c'est la
réponse à l'administration Biden et à
l'inflation
qui est cette grande loi qui était
adoptée pour tenter de développer les
technologies propres et l'énergie et la
transition énergétique aux États-Unis
c'est vraiment intéressant parce qu'on
dirait Ottawa n'a pas le choix que de
dépenser que ça soit subvention etc pour
que tous les investissements de cette
économie verte cette révolution verte ne
se fasse pas au sud de la frontière mais
aussi au Canada donc c'est la réponse
quand même pas mal d'argent Gérald 90
c'est une réponse qui est costaud aux
400 milliards de l'administration Biden
c'est costaud on verra ce que ça va
donner très exactement parce que là dans
le fond le Canada se bat avec les
États-Unis puis avec d'autres
juridictions dans le monde pour attirer
des investissements attirer des
investissements privés en disant nous
sommes là avec un crédit de 15 ou un
crédit de 30 % pour vous encourager à
investir bon on a parlé hier on retrouve
bel et bien de l'aide pour aider les
Canadiens à faire face à l'inflation la
fameuse aide pour l'épicerie là
exactement qui a pas trop rapport avec
l'épicerie dans le fond parce que c'est
un crédit TPS et le crédit sur la TPS
qui est bonifié la plupart des aliments
qu'on achète à l'épicerie non pas de tps
mais le but ici c'est vraiment de donner
un soutien supplémentaire au Canadien
qui en ont besoin les familles qui font
moins de 49000 dollars 11 millions de
ménages au total ça va donner un
paiement unique supplémentaire pour les
célibataires de 234 dollars pour un
couple certains enfants de 36$ une
famille monoparate pour l'année
une fois parce que le crédit TPS tombe
quatre fois par année donc dans le
prochain crédit ou dans l'autre ensuite
lorsque le projet de loi sera adopté il
y aura ce montant supplémentaire famille
monoparentale un enfant 234 et un couple
avec deux enfants aura droit à 467
dollars le ministrella annonce également
la réduction en tout cas la volonté de
réduire ce qu'on appelle les frais
indésirables je pense aux frais de
itinérance en télécommunication ou les
frais sur Visa MasterCard pour les
petites entreprises l'objectif du
gouvernement fédéral ici et de réduire
ses frais là et de travailler avec les
autorités publiques les frais sur les
biais de spectacles également et les
frais sur les bagages excessifs et puis
on va augmenter la possibilité pour les
étudiants de retirer jusqu'à 8000
dollars au lieu de 5000 dollars au
premier retrait de leur régime
enregistré des pariétudes donc c'est un
soutien aux étudiants dans le fond et
vont quand même frappé de plein fouet
par l'inflation en ce moment et puis
autre mesure les soins dentaires je vous
en ai parlé l'année passée Patrice je
vous en parle parce que le gouvernement
ajoute 8 milliards d'argent neuf sur 5
ans autrement dit le grand programme de
soins dentaires accessibles pour les
ménages dont le revenu est inférieur à
90000 dollars coûte pas mal plus cher
que prévu et de toute façon le NPD avait
demandé au libéraux ça faisait partie de
leurs conditions de mettre plus d'argent
de financer davantage ce programme là
alors 13 milliards sur cinq ans dont 8
milliards d'argent neuf ça c'est
beaucoup d'argent encore une fois là ça
s'apparent une évidence ma réponse mais
je veux dire moi je le vois pour la
première fois on rajoute de l'argent
c'est la c'est le NPD là c'est la
caution pour pouvoir gouverner jusqu'en
mais tout comme la bonification du
crédit TPS c'était une attente également
du NPD là dessus le gouvernement dans le
fond dépense il continue de dépenser
essaie de se restreindre mais en même
temps les transferts en santé sont dans
le budget le 46 milliards dont on a
parlé au cours des dernières semaines
puis le 13 milliards pour les soins
dentaires c'est dans le budget également
puis tous les crédits d'impôts avec les
technologies propres et la stratégie
pour répondre aux Américains d'où le
retour rouge
provoquer mais juste qu'on souligne bien
il n'y a plus de dates pour un déficit
zéro c'était 27 28 ça n'existe plus ça
n'existe plus parce qu'on dépense encore
et parce que l'économie est presque à
zéro pour cent présentement on s'en va
en récession donc dans les circonstances
le gouvernement aurait dû aurait pu se
restreindre davantage pour faire baisser
son niveau de dépense qui atteindre
l'équilibre budgétaire mais le choix qui
a été fait et de continuer de soutenir
de cibler une partie des canadiens les
plus vulnérables et moins nantis les
aider à faire face à l'inflation et avec
un programme universel comme les et
d'aller de l'avant aussi avec quelque
chose qui est quand même assez
structurant Patrice c'est à dire
l'innovation
la compétitivité les technologies
propres pour l'avenir économique passe
par là il faut investir parce que si on
le fait pas chez nous les autres le font
en transport je restais dans les projets
verts en fin de transport en commun il y
a de l'argent pour le métro de Montréal
oui il y a de l'argent en infrastructure
avec une entente avec les provinces il
restait de l'argent avec le Québec qui
n'avait pas été dépensé et là on
confirme une entente avec le
gouvernement du Québec le gouvernement
fédéral qui va injecter via investir au
Canada ce programme d'infrastructures
695 millions de dollars pour le
prolongement de la ligne bleue du métro
de Montréal donc c'est écrit en petit
dans le budget mais c'est là c'est de
l'argent pour faire avancer ce projet et
sur l'autoroute bonne aventure
réaménagement de la partie fédérale de
l'autoroute en boulevard urbain vous
savez qu'une partie de cet autoroute est
fédérale de de juridiction fédérale
l'entretien et réparation on parle d'un
milliard de dollars sur neuf ans
d'investissement je vous ai parlé de
réduction de dépenses alors le
gouvernement veut montrer une image que
qu'on a un contrôle des dépenses et
qu'on se restreint dans les dépenses
donc par exemple
tous les contrats à Mackenzie là on veut
les réduire sur la consultation tous les
déplacements les voyages des
travailleurs fédéraux on veut réduire
également ça il faut dire qu'on avait
quand même pas mal réduit durant la
covid-19 7 milliards d'épargne aller
chercher l'économie sur cinq ans on veut
réduire les dépenses dans les ministères
de 7 milliards sur quatre ans dans les
sociétés d'État d'un milliard 300
millions sur quatre ans faut trouver des
économies et le gouvernement dit il y a
des sommes non dépensées qu'on va
pouvoir réaffecter ailleurs 6 milliards
400 millions sur les six prochaines
années
à ceux et celles qui se posent des
questions sur le logement et on a
beaucoup parlé dans le budget du Québec
combien le budget du Québec pouvait être
décevant sur le logement mais dans le
budget fait des rail il y a rien de
supplémentaire pour construire davantage
de logements abordable ou de logements
sociaux il y a déjà des stratégies de
construction de logements ça ne change
pas on ajoute une stratégie de logement
autochtone 4 milliards sur 7 ans et le
compte d'épargne libre d'impôts pour
l'accès une première propriété qui est
une série d'avantages fiscaux pour
encourager les gens et pour aider les
gens à acheter une première propriété ça
avait été annoncé dans le dernier budget
c'est en vigueur la semaine prochaine
1er avril 2023 si les institutions
financières sont en capacité bien sûr de
vous l'offrir et mon dernier tableau
c'est sur le PIB pour vous montrer que
la croissance est à zéro 0,3% prévu
cette année et seulement 1,5% l'an
prochain le gouvernement du Canada
reconnaît qu'on s'en va en récession et
qu'on s'en va dans une récession qu'on
dit modéré selon le secteur privé mais
cette croissance elle est très faible et
les plus faible que tout ce qui était
prévu jusqu'à maintenant donc vous
faites l'addition une croissance
économique à zéro des dépenses qui
demeurent élevées donc des déficits qui
demeurent plus élevés une dette qui
augmente et un équilibre budgétaire qui
remit au calendrier donc 40 milliards de
déficit cette année je crois donc c'est
tout au-delà de des prévisions qui
avaient été faites même récemment donc
on est dans le rouge Madeleine blémorin
alors un mot pour décrire le budget
oui Patrice vous avez
je m'excuse je m'entends beaucoup dans
les oreilles vous avez dit tout à
l'heure on n'a pas le choix d'investir
au Canada pour ne pas se voir siphonner
tous les investissements aux États-Unis
donc je dirais que c'est un gouvernement
qui est en mode réaction réaction pour
réagir à l'inflation réaction pour
réagir justement à cet investissement
qui est je suis désolé Patrice c'est
vraiment
mes amis Clément et Michel c'est là il y
a pas de souci on est on est tout un
groupe on va s'entraider
tour de table puis on va amener vous
quatre dès qu'on peut Clément Gignac bon
là vous êtes libre de parole alors on
est dans le rouge pression pour dépenser
pour faire concurrence aux Américains
dans l'économie verte pression pour
redonner à ceux qui en ont besoin un peu
pour le l'inflation pression
on n'a pas parlé de la défense j'ai de
voir pour les des grands projets que
votre une synthèse de vos impressions
mais c'est clair que c'est un travail
d'équilibré si vous savez vous l'avez
dit c'est un gouvernement minoritaire
donc toutes les on le voit du côté des
soins dentaires c'est coûte à peu près
le double de ce que nous avait dit
l'automne dernier donc c'est substantiel
mais s'il veut rester au pouvoir il y a
pas bien le choix de répondre aux
demandes du NPD puis par ailleurs
l'investissement dans les technologies
propres ben si on veut être compétitif
les États-Unis faut pas c'est gros comme
chiffre le patrice 80 milliards sur 10
ans quand on compare ça aux États-Unis
400 milliards tu disais on a à peu près
le 10e du poids des États-Unis donc
c'est le double de ce que je m'attendais
donc la bonne nouvelle je compte la
bonne nouvelle je veux dire est-ce que
je suis simpliste dans mes restons
là-dessus c'est important 80 milliards
sur 10 ans les Américains c'est 370
milliards sur 10 ans là je me disais on
va être autour de 33 que Gérald me
disait 80 j'ai dit bon Dieu qu'est-ce
que je comprends pas c'est pas stress le
quand on pense à 80 milliards dont les
tristes est propre même les sociétés
il y a quand même des trucs comme les
provinces au niveau des sociétés d'État
Hydro-Québec voyaient avoir droit pour
les électricité propre on parle de la
boucle d'Atlantique là qui est des
négociations entre le Québec vous
Brunswick les Maritimes même si sociétés
justement parce qu'il y a eu quelques
éléments c'est pour lui dans ce budget
on l'écoute
c'est la plus grande expansion du
système de santé en une génération cela
va changer des vies nous en sommes très
fiers ça va vraiment aider les Canadiens
les Canadiens de façon concrète nous
sommes également fiers d'avoir
fait épargner au canadiens de l'argent
avec le congé de la TPS on appelle ça la
réduction de l'épicerie cela va changer
le quotidien des gens nous sommes très
fiers de cela nous sommes fiers aussi
d'être en mesure de relier les
investissements du gouvernement a de
bons salaces là c'est du nouveau
nous allons donner des institutifs pour
s'attaquer aux crises climatiques si il
y a également des garanties pour des
emplois syndiqués à bon salaire nous en
sommes très fiers
on va surveiller dès qu'il aura dès
qu'il parle en français on va y
retourner mais il est il est satisfait
bon bien sûr investissement soin
dentaire Gérald le disait c'était énorme
on rajoute 8 milliards donc alors on
continue Clément continuer sur votre
lancée puis après on fait un tour de
table complet mais le NPD bien sûr on
est satisfait là mais Clément donc même
vous êtes habitués vous avez été surpris
par l'ampleur de l'investissement de la
révolution verte il y a des bonnes
nouvelles et moins bonne nouvelle les
bonnes nouvelles c'est vraiment un
investit dans le futur il faut être
compétitif les États-Unis on est a pas
le choix d'agir et on va favoriser toute
la transition verte et je pense que pour
une fois je vois vraiment un plan
d'action crédit pour être ma déception
c'est vraiment on voit l'empreinte d'une
ou bien ça le mirage de l'équilibre
budgétaire donc on avait l'impression
l'automne passer on y va avec des on va
être des mesures supplémentaires le
déficit reste autour de 40 milliards et
le ratio d'endettement en fait
s'accélère pour la prochaine année donc
j'ai des déceptions là-dessus j'ai aucun
engagement d'encrage budgétaire et par
contre au niveau des investissement le
potentiel économie à long terme ça c'est
quand même une bonne nouvelle Madeleine
et Michel et Gérald Madeleine d'abord
vous vous entendez bien là oui on
dépense on assume on dépense on est du
côté du NPD et là il y aura deux camps
clairs clairement défini au Canada oui
absolument donc le gouvernement dit
qu'il n'a pas le choix de dépenser pas
le choix de dépenser sur trois piliers
l'inflation d'abord en doublant le
crédit pour la TPS en disant on n'a pas
le choix d'aider les Canadiens les plus
vulnérables il y a une partie de
marketing là dedans par contre Patrice
il double un crédit qui existait déjà
donc c'est une prolonge une mesure qu'il
avait mise en place à l'automne dernier
mais l'appel maintenant un rhum nouveau
remboursement pour l'épicerie même si
c'est pas nécessairement destiné à
l'épicerie
c'est pour aider les plus vulnérables
donc il dépense aussi pour justement
comme on le disait tout à l'heure avec
les autres invités pour être
concurrentiel face aux États-Unis dans
la transition économique pour une
transition verte et finalement il
dépense aussi pour répondre aux demandes
du NPD et reprendre aux demandes des
provinces pour ce qui est de la Santé et
des Soins Dentaires même si ça coûte
plus cher que prévu pour les soins
dentaires presque le double de ce qui
avait été prévu aussi parce que lui on
le vient dans l'entendu en anglais Jack
meeting il est Michel C il est ravi il
dit oui il y a quelques déceptions ici
et là mais dans le fond il est ravi lui
il a réussi à forcer ce programme
dentaire pas canadien qui va coûter
quand même une fortune
vous savez que lorsque les conservateurs
menacent de prendre le pouvoir vos
électeurs sans avoir chez les libéraux
le pari qu'il a fait c'est de dire moi
je vais avoir un certain nombre de
choses sur pouvoir dire c'est moi qui a
fait ça si je n'avais pas été là le plan
d'Ampère il serait pas là alors
évidemment le gouvernement est en
minoritaire il n'y a pas le choix si
vous voulez que d'accepter les
conditions du NPD mais tout ça se
négocie évidemment mais si moi ce qui
m'a vraiment le plus surpris c'est la
même chose que vous patriez j'avais fait
même calcul on va on va investir
différents deux fois plus que les
Américains sur l'économie verte moi je
m'attendais pas à autant et c'est très
clair puis on le fait pendant l'épisode
de Monsieur Biden c'est Trudeau qui
avait l'air de dire ouais ils ont un
gros paquet d'argent juste à mettre
là-dedans on peut pas passer en deuxième
ne veut pas passer en dessous et donc
c'est c'est le 80 milliards dans le
budget c'est quand même assez
considérable
se dit si jamais moi en 2025 je pars en
tout cas il y aura ça que je veux
imprimer comme route politique le
clairement il y a comme une déclaration
là
Gérald sur et Clément disait je suis
inquiet sur le taux d'endettement
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus bon difficile de cette année
plus important mais effectivement il y a
plus de carottes là on avance vers on
sait pas quand là pour le retour à
l'équilibre sur le tout d'endettement
sur le niveau de la dette le Canada
demeure quand même l'un des pays les
plus en santé financières du monde
entier avec une note de temple il y a
pas de problème avec ça sauf qu'avant la
pandémie on était autour de 30%. là on
est à 42 et on était monté à 45 on est
tombé à 42 et là tout à coup à un moment
où il n'y a plus de dépenses covid
plutôt que de continuer à faire baisser
la dette fédérale la dette augmente la
dette augmente parce qu'on dépense
encore et on dépense plus qu'avant la
covid pratiquement donc je pense encore
une économie qui est à zéro l'inflation
qui qui était un vent dans le dos sur
les revenus à la hausse pour le
gouvernement fédérale va être en train
de disparaître tranquillement on est
rendu à 5% on était à 8%, ça s'améliore
alors le trajet on nous dit toujours
faut regarder à long terme je suis
d'accord mais on nous dit ça chaque
année alors à chaque année on nous dit
de regarder à long terme puis finalement
on voit que la cette année ça va monter
mais après ça va baisser l'année d'après
on nous dit la même chose alors la dette
augmente continue d'augmenter c'est un
défi pour pour le gouvernement du Canada
et pour ce gouvernement précisément
d'arrêter de trop dépenser et de revenir
quelque part proche de l'équilibre
budgétaire dès qu'on s'y approche un peu
on s'en éloigne encore sur le plan
politique je ne sais pas trop comment on
s'en sort avec ça surtout que ça fait
longtemps qu'il y a eu des surplus au
Canada mais sur le plan financier il est
certain que le Canada de plus en plus de
difficultés à revenir sur une
trajectoire d'équilibre on avait
beaucoup on a beaucoup dit la semaine
dernière lors de la visite de Monsieur
Biden qui avait des pressions on le sait
pour des Américains entre autres pour le
Canada dépense davantage en défense je
ne vois pas dans les tableaux que vous
avez préparés Gérald une augmentation de
la défense est-ce que il y a plus
d'argent qui s'en va dans la défense il
n'y a pas plus d'argent il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'argent je devrais dire on est
certainement pas dans l'objectif
d'atteindre le 2 % du PIB
d'argent militaire et d'argent en
défense comme l'exige l'OTAN ou comme
l'expert le temps et comme l'espérerait
également les Américains je vous signale
simplement que le gouvernement sur
l'Ukraine le budget accorde à l'Ukraine
un presse supplémentaire de 2 milliards
400 millions de dollars pour 2023
quelques mesures ici et là mais rien de
qui change la donne sur le plan de la
défense ok autre chose qui vous
Madeleine qui est peut-être qui a retenu
votre attention dans des choix des
mesures ou dans la posture politique de
ce budget
pour la posture police politique Patrice
on peut parler justement de cette
décision de ne pas revenir à l'équilibre
budgétaire parce que ça reste une
décision on peut bien dire le
gouvernement n'avait pas le choix
d'investir pour être concurrentiel face
aux Américains on peut bien dire il y
avait pas le choix d'investir pour
maintenir l'entente avec le NPD
intacte mais gouverner c'est quand même
une question de choix et il a fait le
pari que ça lui coûterait moins cher
politiquement de dépenser et de reporter
encore une fois le retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire c'est un pari en fait qui le
fait depuis qu'il est au pouvoir c'est
comme si on ne voyait pas dans
l'équilibre budgétaire quelque chose qui
était nécessairement si important face à
l'électorat canadien évidemment si le
ménage l'entente avec le LBD et se rend
quand même plus vulnérable face aux
conservateurs parce que les
conservateurs lui reprochent de toutes
sortes de façon Patrice de dépenser
parfois on utilise des symboles comme
les chambres d'hôtel à 6000 dollars mais
en même temps ce qu'on voit dans ce
budget-ci c'est aussi une tentative de
montrer qu'on est capable d'essayer
d'aller chercher des économies à droite
à gauche notamment dans la machine du
gouvernement avec moins de dépenses pour
les fonctionnaires pour moins de frais
en consultant aussi une réduction de
certaines dépenses dans les ministères
mais au total on dépense quand même plus
qu'on économise mais pour ce qui est de
la machine du gouvernement on veut aussi
montrer qu'elle fonctionne cette machine
là on a par exemple une section c'est
dans on va améliorer le fonctionnement
dans les aéroports on ne va améliorer le
fonctionnement la demande des passeports
donc ça ça se retrouve dans le budget
encore une fois un peu en mode défensif
là-dessus ok très bien je vous préviens
tout de suite Gérald je vais vous
demander mais je vais avant de parler à
Clément et à Michel mais je vais vous
demander pour les consommateurs de
m'éclairer parce que vous avez parlé des
freins désirables et tout ça j'ai
quelques
les trucs très concrets mais Clément
est-ce que est-ce que même malgré ses
dépenses et malgré les déficites et
malgré la dette calma et le ratio qui
augmente est-ce que ça tient la route
pour le milieu financier des affaires ou
une lumière jaune après vous qui
s'allume là où on en est là mais je
pense que si on regarde les hypothèses
économiques c'est hypothèses que le
médecin du secteur privé on prévoit une
légère récession d'ailleurs Gérald lui
expliquer mais vous savez ça prive quand
même de 5 milliards par année de
recettes le fait qu'on ne revisait à la
baisse au niveau des projections
économiques des économistes donc on en
est là donc les hypothèses économiques
ça va moi ma déception c'est vraiment le
fait que si on n'avait pas dépensé
depuis l'énoncé économique l'énoncé
économique de l'automne dernier c'est
pas eu des nouvelles initiatives on a eu
un décès de 30 milliards ce soir au lieu
de 43 milliards pour l'année qui
s'achève dans deux jours là on y est
quand même y aller avec différentes
dépenses initiatives et là par la suite
on voit qu'on se prive de retourner à
l'équilibre de budgétaire c'est des
choix vous savez cette entreprise de NPD
il y a deux volets il y a des volets au
niveau de la chance en taille celui de
la assurance médicament avant la fin de
2023 heureusement c'est pas là
heureusement parce que sinon en fait le
défi ne diminuerait peut-être
possiblement même pas là donc clairement
il faut revoir les priorités du
gouvernement on a fait un choix on ne
faut dire c'est un gouvernement mineur
on doit respecter les contraintes au
niveau de la défense rapidement j'ai eu
le temps de consulter je posais la
question au fonctionnaires il y a à
peine 83 millions de plus là pour Norade
et sur cinq ans pour Norade et le temps
donc on reste à peu près
3 1.4% du PIB on est loin de la cible de
2% qui était exigé très bien Michel un
mot sur cette posture dont je parlais
avec Madeleine clairement on s'assume
puis on est du côté avec le NPD puis on
dit aux conservateur oui il y aura deux
choix deux visions politiques nous on
pense que dépenser pour les dents
dépenser pour la nouvelle économie verte
là mettons ça ce chapeau là c'est
rentable
les conservateurs vont bien sûr on
entend monsieur poignard tous les jours
par les baisses d'impôts alors donc
c'est leur créneau le gouvernement est
dans un autre créneau très clairement
mais il y a plusieurs de gens je crois
du monde des affaires et puis que le
souvenir tout à l'heure les dépenses
sont économie verte ils n'ont pas
considérer ça comme comme quelque chose
de mauvais ils vont dire hey on vend
faire ce qu'il faut pour un bon français
à côté les États-Unis et pour faire
quelque chose qui est du développement
intéressant alors je suis pas sûr que
dans les milieux économiques en général
ce budget là va être aussi mal reçu qui
va l'être par le Parti conservateur par
exemple c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de
baisse d'impôts de l'autre côté
c'est pas la demande qu'on sent non plus
dans l'opinion publique beaucoup
il y avait pas de contrairement au
Québec il y avait pas eu de promesse
donc on savait pas en fait ça aurait été
très très surprenant dans le contexte
économique et compte tenu des dépenses
par ailleurs Gérald je vous demandais on
a quand même vous disiez
consommation on veut quand on envoie des
messages que l'on veut positif au
consommateurs est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est des guidis ou c'est vraiment
important là
votre premier mot me semble plus juste
Patrice je trouve que ça ressemble à des
guidis mais ça peut faire ça va être de
ma faute mais
il y a toujours de ça dans le budget il
y a toujours toutes sortes de il y a à
peu près 200 petits paragraphes de
petites choses qu'on vient semer à
droite et à gauche mais qui peuvent
avoir quand même une
résonance dans la population parce que
quand je vous parle des freins
désirables je vous disais les frais
d'itinérance les frais d'itinérance des
télécommunications
des frais d'événements ou de concerts et
les frais de bagages excessifs et de
frais d'expédition alors les frais de
bagages accessibles à l'aéroport vous
arrivez avec un bagage de trop ça coûte
une fortune les frais sur les billets de
spectacle beaucoup de gens puis même des
poursuites et des recours collectifs
là-dessus vivent ça et les frais
indésirables aussi les frais
d'itinérance donc le gouvernement dit
nous allons collaborer avec les
organismes de réglementation les
provinces et les territoires pour
réduire ses frais là c'est pas le
domaine c'est pas précis c'est pas
chiffré il y a une volonté de mettre de
l'ordre exactement ok l'autre chose que
je voulais vous demander l'autre chose
c'est dans les réductions de départ vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est un peu
comme la céréale on veut montrer le côté
sucré mais le côté plus aride et
les consultations
donc les entreprises de consultations
est-ce que - 7 milliards sur 5 ans
est-ce que vous avez pu réfléchir c'est
tout beaucoup ça comme réduction ou pas
c'est pas c'est pas énorme et comme
disait quelqu'un dans le huis clos il y
a une bonne partie de l'argent aussi
c'est sur les déplacements et les
voyages depuis la covid
il y a beaucoup moins de déplacements il
y a beaucoup moins de voyages et il y a
beaucoup moins de dépenses et je pense
qu'on ajoute aussi l'aspect de
consultation compte tenu du scandale sur
l'utilisation des agences de
consultation comme mécanisé alors c'est
une somme sur cinq ans c'est pas énorme
mais il y a quand même une volonté de
surveiller de plus près ce type de
dépenses
très bien bon ben nous voilà informés
d'intervenir c'est que dans le fond moi
ce que je regarde sur le ratio dépense
des programmes au PIB pour voir si on se
lance dans des dépenses tout azimut
là-dessus on garde le contrôle parce que
c'est là que le gouvernement pour être
vulnérable
pour être critiqué de se lancer dans des
dépenses de musique donc un message ici
qu'on va contrôler on va gérer on va
réduire les dépenses de voyage et on
réussit à maintenir le ratio dépense au
PB autour de
15.5%. et sauf évidemment ça me rassure
donc vous dites ils sont quand même pas
parti tout azimut partout il y a des
initiatives mais c'est des initiatives
qui ont peur comme l'énergie propre faut
vraiment on voit les forces États-Unis
donc faut rester compétitif et que ça
c'est un investissement pour moi c'est
plutôt un investissement qu'une dépense
l'origine d'assurance soins dentaire
soit c'est un engagement qui avait déjà
pris depuis un an qui est là dedans mais
si on regarde le reste là puis il faut
aussi dire que ce budget inclut les
demandes au niveau de la santé des
provinces là c'est pas loin de 20 sur
cinq ans ils vont voir même un chèque de
2 milliards avant le 31 mars clairement
il y avait des contraintes donc les
provinces il y avait le programme
américain qu'on devait et il y avait les
soins dentaires mais si on regarde le
reste on peut pas prétendre que ce
gouvernement là se lance dans les
dépenses aux États-Unis il y a Jacques
médecine qui va être avec Madeleine mais
juste avant je pense que j'ai le temps
de vous poser une autre question Géral
et Clément et Michel c'est sur le
remboursement de tps là on a vu le
tableau ce que ça veut dire pour les on
a Monsieur si on va aller voir Monsieur
Sims intéressant parce que c'est un peu
en partie en partie son budget quand
même Madeleine on vous écoute oui on dit
à l'émission il y a un instant c'est en
partie votre budget avez-vous cette
impression là que la marque NPD est
suffisamment dans ce budget là pour que
vous puissiez l'appuyer on peut dire
clairement que une économisation de
1700 dollars va être réalisé à cause de
nous avec les mesures dans ce budget
qu'on a forcé les gourmands de faire
donc les grands éléments pour aider les
gens dans cette envie ce temps difficile
c'est des grâces et nos affaires on est
fiers de ça le soins dentaire le fait
que on est élargi cette programme pour
inclure nos aînés c'est grâce à nous si
nos affaires le fait qu'on a une on a du
blé le crédit de la TPS c'est que c'est
quelque chose que on a forcement de
faire on l'appelle maintenant le
remboursement pour l'épicerie mais c'est
ce qu'on a accompli ce qu'on a fait et
on est fier de ça parce que ça va
vraiment aider les gens ça va vraiment
aider les gens mais ça va vraiment
coûter plus cher aussi monsieur sing on
parle de 13 milliards de dollars c'est à
peu près deux fois plus que ce qui avait
été budgété au départ qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on se soit trompé au gouvernement ou
peut-être ou NPD à ce point-là dans la
facture de ce programme donc on a vu
qu'il y a une grande besoin parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas de la
couverture donc après on a fait une
autre analyse le bureau de gouvernement
a fait une autre analyse et ça coûte un
peu plus cher assez important de
reconnaître ces à cause de l'effet qu'il
y a une grande manque des services pour
les gens le fait qu'ils n'ont pas accès
aux soins dentaire c'est c'est pourquoi
le coup est un peu élevé mais on a dit
que il y a des autres mesures qu'on peut
prendre pour être plus prudent on peut
annuler les subventions aux entreprises
d'ateliers ce sont des milliards de
dollars qui on donne aux entreprises qui
ont gagné un profit
massif dans les années passées donc on
peut arrêter ça on peut arrêter les
échappentoires qui étaient en sorte
qu'on perde des milliards de dollars
donc il y a des façons d'être Proudhon
avec les soins d'engage je pense que
c'est une bonne investissement dans les
gens je vous remercie monsieur c'est
alors on a la réponse à votre question
Madeleine il va bien sûr le NPD va voter
pour ce budget la question Patrice c'est
de savoir jusqu'à quand il va appuyer ce
gouvernement parce que le gouvernement
pourrait potentiellement être au pouvoir
jusqu'à 2025 les libéraux ont fait
exprès pour essayer de
étaler dans le temps le déploiement du
programme dentaire et dans le budget
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est pas clair à
quel moment ça va être complètement mis
en oeuvre il y aurait peut-être une
stratégie de la part des libéraux
d'attendre un petit peu justement pour
garder le NPD en laisse un peu plus
longtemps pour les obliger à continuer
de les appuyer tant et aussi longtemps
que le programme ne sera pas
complètement mis en oeuvre ça me tromper
puis j'ai vu quelques sondages là dessus
il y a pas beaucoup de Canadiens qui
souhaitent une campagne électorale
maintenant un autre gouverneur de
minoritaire une autre élection de suite
je pense à alors Monsieur sings sans ça
aussi et profite pour récolter des gains
avoir
parlons de ce qui va concerner
directement les gens qui reçoivent déjà
un crédit pour TPS d'abord est-ce que
j'ai raison de dire Gérald que c'est les
gens qui reçoivent déjà un crédit pour
tes fesses qui vont recevoir un
supplément au cours des prochaines
semaines unique j'aimerais qu'on revoit
le tableau que vous m'expliquez comment
comment s'est basé pour déterminer que
ces 234 pour un célibataires par exemple
je ne connais pas la formule
mathématique là pour arriver à ce
montant là mais on va
augmenter le crédit d'impôt qu'on avait
déjà augmenté parce qu'on l'avait
augmenté pour 6 mois puis on décide de
l'augmenter encore pour refléter en
quelque sorte les coûts supplémentaires
alimentaires à l'épicerie alors que le
taux d'inflation à l'épicerie demeure
autour de 9,10 % le taux général est
autour de 5 à l'épicerie c'est 9 10%. je
ne suis pas convaincu qu'on a fait le
calcul de la facture moyenne à
l'épicerie
depuis un an pour un célibataire pour
arriver à ce montant là on décide tout
simplement de reprendre une formule qui
existait et d'aider encore les Canadiens
qui sont dans le besoin célibataire deux
personnes coupent les enfants si vous
avez un enfant ça vient bonifier si vous
avez deux enfants ça bonifie encore
davantage ça touche combien de gens ce
qui a droit 11 millions de personnes
donc 11 millions de personnes parce que
c'est tous les gens qui sont en bas de
49 000 en termes de revenus donc ça
touche quand même une bonne portion de
la population puis une bonne partie des
contribuables ça reste quand même ciblé
si on veut des mesures anti-inflation on
pourrait aider les gens à contrer
l'inflation contrairement au
gouvernement du Québec qui a envoyé des
chèques à 95% de la population et si on
décide de cibler davantage et d'aider
une partie des Canadiens qui sont
davantage en difficulté qui sont
davantage frappés par l'inflation sur ce
point Clément donc est-ce que c'est plus
efficace plus ciblée comme ça pour ceux
qui en ont davantage besoin
définitivement je l'avais dit avant de
budget je le répète aujourd'hui
contrairement au gouvernement logo et
est-ce que Géral le dit c'est à peu près
tout le monde qui reçoit des baisses
d'impôts au Québec ça stimule
l'inflation or l'inflation c'est le
problème numéro 1 sont stimule
l'inflation des taux d'intérêts
continuent augmenter donc j'aime
beaucoup mieux ça on parle de deux
points 4 milliards autour de 2.5
milliards c'est quand même modeste quand
on compare à la hauteur de l'économie
canadienne qui est de 2000 milliards
donc et le point que je pourrais
rajouter là-dessus Patrice c'est que ce
chèque là va être versé lorsque le
projet doit être adopté à Chambre des
communes et au Sénat donc voir de la
pression là pour que les sénateurs puis
les parlementaires
on va faire supplémentaire c'est sûr des
aspectateurs pour ce qu'on va avoir de
la pression pour adopter ce vide mais
oui je rappelle que vous êtes sénateur
indépendant maintenant c'est comme ça il
y a plus de sénateur libéraux mais pour
le Québec très bien restez là avec nous
le godebou que vous connaissez
bien sûr titulaire de la chair en
recherche en fiscalité en finance
publique merci de Sherbrooke c'est quoi
de beau rebonsoir on s'est parlé la
semaine dernière d'abord synthèse
qu'est-ce qui vous surprend qu'est-ce
que vous étonne de ce budget Freeland
ce qui était étonnant mettons c'est la
quantité d'argent qui va dans des
crédits d'impôts à l'investissement dans
des trucs propres technologies propres
électricité propre hydrogène propre ça
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de sommes donc
on veut faire un virage environnemental
je crois que c'est le message un point
qui me surprend pas nécessairement c'est
vraiment une volonté de ne pas retourner
à l'équilibre budgétaire ils sont là
depuis 2015
l'équilibre budgétaire est toujours
comme un oasis dans le désert qui dès
qu'on s'en approche finalement ça en
éloigne mirage on était à la mise à jour
un mirage tout à fait à la mise à jour
économique ont été se poser atteinte
d'équilibre budgétaire en 2027-28
mettons on a un déficit en 202728 certes
il s'explique en partie par une
détérioration des conditions économiques
mais il s'explique par les nouvelles
initiatives et pour les nouvelles
initiatives moi je suis pas contre je
pense aux soins dentaires on a vu que ça
va avec l'interview vous venez de faire
que ça va coûter moins cher que prévu ça
peut être un bon programme je trouve que
l'occasion ratée pour le gouvernement
c'est d'yer pas y avoir associé une
source de financement on crée un nouveau
programme permanent sans mettre des
revenus permanents pour le financer je
pense que c'est l'occasion ratée parce
que là ça donnerait une réalité des
coups aux gens les gens pourraient être
pour bonifier je pense que c'est tout à
fait légitime de le faire mais trouver
une source de financement pour le faire
même chose lorsqu'on fait une bonne
éducation des des prestations aux années
trouver une source de financement en ce
moment le gouvernement développe des
nouvelles prestations sans source de
financement c'est peut-être ce qui est
le plus décevant à cet égard là bien que
on n'est pas dans la catastrophe les
déficits vont en réduisant et la dette
va commencer à réduire à partir de
l'année prochaine en proportion du PIB
mais il faut pas être à l'armiste mais
on aurait pu y avoir un peu un peu plus
de tonus pour te retrouver des québecs
1300 milliards mille milliards comme
disait l'autre mais 1300 milliard s la
dette c'est quand même impressionnant
alors Macron micro d'abord macro sur ça
est-ce que Clément Godbout était et qui
imaginant qui est un peu inquiet
êtes-vous inquiet du ratio de la dette
canadienne par rapport à d'autres quand
on se compare etc
lorsqu'on se compare on n'a pas à
s'inquiéter donc on a une bonne note de
crédit on a une dette qui est
relativement faible en proportion du PIB
même quand on compte la dette de
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
la chance qu'on a nous c'est que nos
régimes de retraite comme le régime des
rentes du Québec et le régime de pension
du Canada est un actif dans la
détermination de notre dette bien qu'on
pourrait pas s'en servir pour payer la
dette mais apparaît comme un actif donc
ça nous donne une meilleure comparaison
à l'international cela dit cette ratio
lutte devrait diminuer on devrait avoir
un ancrage plus solide pour une
réduction de la dette parce que je vous
donne un exemple vous avez parlé de 1300
milliards pour la dette mais financer
1300 milliards ça coûte plus cher que
financer 1000 milliards et donc
les intérêts annuels que l'on paye sur
la dette sont passés de l'année 21-22 à
moins de 25 milliards à plus de 50
milliards en 2027 28 et ça c'est des
dépenses annuelles qui n'offrent pas de
service public à la population le goût
les paiements uniques pour l'épicerie
comme ça a été présenté c'est à dire un
supplément de remboursement de la TTS à
ceux qui gagnent moins de 49.000 est-ce
que c'est une mesure efficace pour aider
les gens qui en arrache avec l'inflation
je pense que oui la principale beauté de
cette chose là c'est que c'est un
paiement unique et qu'il est mieux ciblé
par exemple sur le compare au paiement
qui avait été fait du côté du
gouvernement du Québec donc ça le
gouvernement du Québec ratissait
beaucoup plus large 95% des
contribuables il y avait droit ici on
est plus ciblés c'est des revenus pour
un célibataire où on parle de moins de
50 000 mais pour même pour un couple
avec deux enfants on parle de moins de
58000 pour être admissible aux crédit
TPS sans quoi on a pas ce paiement un
éclat donc c'est des aides plus ciblées
et comme Clément Gignac le disait
d'abord que la loi soit votée pour avoir
droit ce paiement là c'est un montant
total pour l'ensemble canadien ça va
bénéficier à 11 millions de ménages et
ça va coûter 2.5 milliards ça peut même
un éclat c'est ça ça coûte deux points 5
puis après ça coûte plus rien c'est
c'est ponctuel c'est une fleur par
exemple tout à fait alors que d'autres
programmes comme une bonification de
pension de sécurité pour le
vieillissement pour les années mais
c'est un montant qui est récurrent
annuel en plus qu'un plus grand nombre
d'années qui va qui va être là d'une
année à l'autre donc il y a une pression
plus grande qu'on fait une annonce
permanente qu'une annonce ponctuelle
donc ça va ça va aider les gens qui vont
recevoir ces sommes là d'une part
d'autre part est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
choses qui vous inquiète qui pourraient
mettre de l'essence sur le feu de
l'inflation
non pas du côté de l'inflation ils
remettent pas d'argent dans les ils font
pas de baisse d'impôts ciblée ils font
pas d'autres éléments donc la seule
façon d'avoir plus d'argent c'est de
bonifie d'avoir le crédit TPS sinon
c'est les dépenses gouvernementales ils
sont ciblés à l'investissement dans les
entreprises donc pour les particuliers
il y a pas beaucoup de changements qui
qu'on peut noter on peut on peut noter
il y a un impôt minimum qui existait que
depuis que c'est Brian meluni en 1986
qui avait mis en place il a été
modernisé dans ce budget-ci il va
s'appliquer à partir de l'année
prochaine mais ils veulent viser
vraiment les mieux nantis puis je sais
pas il y a combien de millions de
déclarations au Canada qui est produite
par année mais on est sans doute autour
de près de 25 millions de déclarations
ça va concerner 31 000 contribua baiser
donc c'est quand même assez ciblé comme
comme un pot minimum là le goût très
clair merci beaucoup à bientôt à la
prochaine au revoir vous voyez le petit
carré en images Gérald et Clément et
Michel c'est et Madeleine c'est Monsieur
poignet qui va venir au micro donner ses
premières impressions
dans ce budget dépensier dans la mesure
où on fait pas de demi-mesure pour
l'économie verte Madeleine à Monsieur
poignet je présume va dire où sont les
baisses d'impôts que j'avais réclamé là
oui c'est un gouvernement dépensier
c'est vraiment le fait que les
conservateurs essaient de faire pour les
libéraux c'est la façon dont ils
essaient de les dépeindre depuis le
début et d'une certaine façon ils ont
des arguments pour le faire parce que
d’années en année le gouvernement
dépense davantage même dans un contexte
où l'économie ralentit où on base le
scénario sur une récession légère mais
une récession quand même le gouvernement
continue de dépenser certains pourraient
dire si j'avais moins dépensé avant
peut-être qu'on aurait eu plus de marge
de manoeuvre maintenant mais le
gouvernement se retrouve face à des
choix il choisit de dépenser il cherche
des économies mais il en trouve pas
autant que ce que représente les
dépenses si je reviens au crédit de tps
donc on appelle maintenant le
remboursement pour l'épicerie c'est la
façon de parler du gouvernement une
façon de vendre ce programme là
c'était une une
une vulnérabilité du Parti libéral face
à l'électorat Patricia la firme abaccuse
que sondé les Canadiens sur toute une
série de dossiers comment vous évaluez
la performance du gouvernement que ce
soit pour la guerre en Ukraine pour la
relation avec oui tout près de vous
Madeleine on va écouter le chef du Bloc
pour le poids de ce budget parce qu'en
effet c'est un budget qui est assez
mince on parle depuis longtemps
d'inflation on craint depuis un bon
moment une récession qui pourrait
frapper l'économie canadienne et
l'économie québécoise et on arrive avec
un budget qui est à très peu de choses
près un copier-coller de l'énoncé
économique de l'automne dernier
on va disposer tout de suite de certains
éléments fondamentaux nous avions déjà
établi que nous n'acceptions pas
l'entente entre Ottawa et les provinces
et le Québec que les provinces et le
Québec ont été obligés d'accepter sinon
c'était rien pour tout et qu'elle n'en
n'avait pas les moyens pour nous les
transferts en santé tels qu'ils ont été
négociés sont inadéquats et à des fous
de rencontrer la demande des provinces
et du Québec à hauteur de 35%, nous ne
sommes pas satisfaits il n'y a
absolument rien dans ce budget pour les
années de 65 à 75 ans pour aller
rejoindre leurs collègues de 75 ans et
plus ni même une augmentation digne de
ce nom incluant pour les gens âgés de 75
ans et plus il n'y a aucune réforme de
l'assurance-emploi aucune bonification
pour les gens qui cotisent et qui n'ont
accès à rien c'est à dire 60% des
cotisants du régime d'assurance emploi
il y a rien du tout il y a par contre
une illustration
extraordinaire du déséquilibre fiscal
l'année dernière le gouvernement a
accumulé en crédit périmés en somme qui
avait été budgété et qui n'ont pas été
dépensés environ 40 milliards de dollars
or il dit cette année qu'il fait un
déficit de 40 milliards de dollars
comprenons-nous bien une chose annule
l'autre et dans les faits le
gouvernement fédéral veut annoncer des
déficits
deuxième élément fondamental il utilise
des équilibre fiscal donc les sommes la
marge que ça dégage pour faire des
investissements à caractère énergétique
lesquels peuvent s'avérer des cachettes
pour de l'écho blanchiment le mot éco
blanchiment est d'autant plus pertinent
que ça passe par des crédits d'impôts
dont on ne saura pas qui a bénéficié il
y a donc des sommes qui iront en
séquestration de carbone cette lubie qui
ne fonctionne toujours pas en hydrogène
gris fait à partir des hydrocarbures de
l'Ouest canadien et caché dans les
investissements pour les énergies dites
propres un financement vraisemblable
pour le nucléaire qui dans le contexte
canadien n'est pas une énergie propre il
y a donc une part significative d'une
somme de 21 milliards de dollars qui ira
en soutien indirect par crédit d'impôts
aux entreprises pétrolières
grâce à ce fameux déséquilibre fiscal
qu'on peut expliquer simplement en ceci
que le gouvernement aperçoit trop
d'argent
en taxes et en impôts par rapport à ce
que sont ces obligations
gouvernementales alors que les provinces
ne perçoivent pas assez d'argent en taxe
et en impôts par rapport à ce que sont
leurs obligations
le gouvernement annonce ainsi que dans
de 30 à 40 ans il aura éliminé la dette
fédérale ou complet alors que selon le
directeur parlementaire du budget
lui-même dans de 30 à 40 ans il y aura
des provinces canadiennes en faillite et
les finances de l'ensemble des provinces
canadiennes se seront détériés
détériorés pardon à un niveau
irrécupérable c'est grâce à ce procédé
que le gouvernement fédéral centralise
et littéralement achètent des pouvoirs
qui sont aux provinces dernière
observation c'est un budget qui n'est
pas un caractère électoral mais c'est un
budget qui met dangereusement la table
pour que celui de 2024 soit résolument à
caractère électoral
les ministres quelle note il donnait à
ce budget là il me dit à plus vous vous
donnez quelle note à ce budget là et
pourquoi
je
ne peux pas commenter la pertinence
précise de l'exercice de mettre une note
mais est-ce que c'est une note de
passage non évidemment enfin que je
mettrai un e parce qu'il ne réussit pas
c'est un budget
à ce budget Freeland en fait on a
compris dès le départ que on estime du
côté du bloc que comme il n'y avait pas
de toute façon les sommes demandées par
les provinces pour le l'accord en santé
ben ça il n'y avait pas la note de
passage et là il a continué avec
d'autres éléments qui l'inquiète mais
essentiellement
puis on l'a vu il y a plusieurs mois de
plusieurs semaines le gouvernement
fédéral n'a pas donné ce que les
provinces demandaient en entièreté pour
les soins de santé Clément Gignac sur ça
mais sur le sur le reste
il dit ce n'est pas un budget électoral
c'est intéressant mais l'an prochain ça
le sera mais effectivement ce n'est pas
un budget électoral sauf pour ce qui a
été donné au NPD bien sûr oui c'est
certainement un budget préleval parce
que sans doute Madeleine et Gérald ont
remarqué à toutes les chapitres on fait
le post mortem depuis 2015 qu'on est au
pouvoir on a fait si on appelle ça on a
réduit aussi la pauvreté donc il y avait
toutes les éléments de faire un bilan du
gouvernement depuis qu'il était au
pouvoir donc par ailleurs les choses
Bloc québécois devra par rapport au
gouvernement logo monsieur Legault qui
semblait quand même satisfait du
meilleur des qui avait pu avoir sa table
donc un petit peu un contraste-le par
rapport au positionnement du
gouvernement du Québec là-dessus mais
clairement c'est un budget du NPD on va
se le dire sans doute le dernier parce
que on aura vraiment pas les moyens des
moyens d'y aller avec l'assurance
médicament à défaut de quoi le défi de
va augmenter au lieu de diminuer donc
j'ai bien hâte de voir
très bien
Gérald on va on va dire au revoir aux
gens de la première chaîne en quelques
secondes mais après j'aimerais qu'on
donne les fesses ayant avant le 17h sur
RDI qui se poursuit mesdames et
messieurs on vous reste vous bougez pas
personne mesdames et messieurs ben les
gens la première chaîne peut toujours
aller sur RDI c'est là que nous on
poursuit cette émission spéciale merci
d'avoir été avec nous et à très bientôt
aux gens de Radio-Canada
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]